filmmaker that i am you know even that
night i was very aware i was going like
you know
i want to make a film about this i
remember talking to her about she's like
what are you talking about i said this
you know this is just this feeling this
feeling this thing about discovering
someone else
that infatuation attraction what it
brings out in you
what are the stakes you know
everything's about stakes in the
screenplay
the stakes are oh if he doesn't get that
then he'll not
achieve this and you know here come all
the plot points
i'm like what are the stakes it's like
you're alive you know
you're just trying to make it through
the world you don't talk about a
character
and experience you show them having the
experience but i never i never
approached someone like that
never i just thought people talking was
so evocative and what they're describing
it has a double effect
because not only does it conjure what
they're talking about in the viewer's
mind because you're not showing it to me
it's more
interesting because you not only do you
get the essence of them and what they're
saying but also what they're talking
about this mythical audience we have
that we think is we know it's small but
it's deep
and we have a bond with them that we're
not going to lie to them
we would meet and you know i might tell
him like hey when you
at a party this year or if you meet a
girl and find yourself in an intimate
conversation i want you to write down
what you say you know i would i won't i
want
like a real teenage conversation here i
remember moving there just thinking oh
this is all i really want i just want to
be here watch movies make movies a lot
of people
thought oh you'd have to go to new york
or la to do what i do but i was like no
i'm just going to make it work here
[Music]
i was really looking for those little
things i wanted the film to feel like a
memory really
of like him maybe looking back over his
childhood from
the vantage point of the young adult
that he is at the end
so i really wanted to avoid i mean just
just personally i remember thinking
those big moments that
are so are made you know
they make movies about them they it's
represented a lot i was kind of like
those moments
aren't what i remember you know i
approach everything like that you know
when i make a teenage movie it's like
well i was
what do i remember and here's the
essence of what i remember
and i was kind of trying to do that here
it's like well
why do i remember this little moment
that no one else would
you know it's a collection of kind of
lesser moments
so i could talk about the film on a
console oh 12 years everybody gets older
people would ask well so what happens in
the movie and i was like
not much you know but it i was counting
on the cumulative effect
of you know the way we perceive cinema
you really invest in these characters
and i felt
that it potentially could have the
significance that it has in one's own
life
these little memories if the investment
was there in these characters
that these little things that have no
business being in a narrative they don't
advance character they don't
advance plot you know what has to be in
a movie
that you actually could have it that be
the essence of the movie
and it would matter because you are
invested in these
in these characters after doing two
sprawling ensembles of slacker and dazed
and confused i remember having this urge
inside me to
take those methods of how i kind of
shape material and work with cast
i remember thinking it's time to do that
intimate story and i've been thinking
about this since i remember it was the
fall of 89
i was just kind of leaving new york
i went through philly and i was visiting
my sister for one night and i was
leaving the next day
and i just met this young woman at a toy
store my sister and i we wandered into a
toy store and she was working there
she was kind of flirting with me and we
just had this kind of connection
and i did something i would never do i'm
kind of shy i wrote her a little note
and slipped it to her and said hey i'm
in 10 49 you know you
would you want to go get a drink you
know do something after and she went
back yeah sure i'm like
wow okay and so we really spent that
whole night just walking around philly
it was just kind of that
that magical thing that happens between
people filmmaker that i
am you know even that night i was very
aware i was going like you know
i want to make a film about this i
remember talking to her about she's like
what are you talking about i said this
you know this
just this feeling this feeling this
thing about discovering someone else
that infatuation attraction what it
brings out in you
all that while making slacker i
determined that on my next moment i want
to make i have this teenage movie i want
to make it's just
kids riding around looking for something
to do that was my central metaphor for
that movie
but it was set in the 70s you know the
music alone would be expensive the
recreation of the period so it was quote
unquote a real movie you know i got to
make a very personal film
about what i remember high school
feeling like
all kind of synthesized through one
night you know the last night of school
in 1976. one of the great things about
getting to do this is you there is a
cathartic aspect you do get to
recycle things from your own experience
or that's where i i really do work from
a pretty specific autobiographical place
at least as a jumping off
point i think there hadn't been a lot of
hit teenage movies at that moment
you know the archetype is rebel without
a cause you know there's a car wreck
there's death
you know it's such a big deal and i'm
just working from a personal place i'm
just saying
well i don't remember a lot of that the
essence for me of being a teenager was
just
riding around looking for something to
do i crammed everything interesting that
happened to me like my freshman year
high school
into kind of one day where nothing's
happening but everything's happening
we live in the same town and he's
practically like my nephew or something
i just feel like he's family so
if i had an event or something he and
his parents might come
we would meet and you know i might tell
him like hey when you
at a party this year or if you meet a
girl and find yourself in an intimate
conversation i want you to write down
what you say you know i would i won't i
want
like a real teenage conversation here or
you know so he became
a collaborator you know a full artistic
collaborator with
with kind of you know assignments with a
guy who
you know saw the big picture of what the
film was trying to
articulate and was on board for it so it
was fun to see his
maturation from a kid that you know when
you're working with a seven-year-old
it's it's kind of a manipulation oh now
look here and you know
and then to see him full-blown artistic
collaborator
it was a fun trajectory i guess i mean
that's where i'm i'm pretty
promiscuous that way probably because i
think anything can be a story
you know it's like yeah the most simple
thing that happened in your life or
or something very personal or obviously
there's there's
big epic stories out there you can be
attracted to so i kind of feel like i've
done a pretty big gamut
people think they have you oh here's the
kind of stories you tell i go oh really
because to me they seem very
wide-ranging but i ask about what
happens in
in before midnight nothing i mean i
really like the film but no you're about
to see
nothing yeah but i have always rebelled
against that i remember her you know the
great sam fuller
you know i remember him speaking
anything he says
cinema's about don't talk about it
show it you know and every film rtf
teacher will say you know it's a visual
medium just
you know used to show you don't talk
about it you don't talk about a
character
an experience you show them having the
experience but i never i never
approached cinema like that it never i
always thought people talking
was so evocative and what they're
describing it has a double effect
people talking can be wonderfully
cinematic yeah because not only does it
conjure what they're talking about in
the viewer's mind because you're not
showing it to me it's more
interesting because you not only do you
get the essence of them and what they're
saying but also what they're talking
about waking life probably has the
longest gestation of any film
i've ever done in that the idea for the
story
predated my interest in film even it was
based on a dream i had my senior in high
school
that moved around in my head for 20
years
and it never worked the film in my head
didn't work it was too literal it just
never worked but when i saw this
animation sample that these friends of
mine were working on
it was this kind of computer-based
version of rotoscoping i was like oh
it just hit me rather quickly it was one
of those great mashups of
collision of like forming content this
idea i had
suddenly i go that thing that doesn't
work in my head
will work if it looks like that we were
off to the races
i started talking to them about it and
again it was a film i couldn't really
explain that's when i know i'm in good
territory when i can't really explain
the film i'm working on
it wasn't conventionally scripted i had
pages of notes and dialogues and ideas
and scenes
and again another one of those miracles
of like okay
can i get this film made i remember at
the time personally just thinking
like i was having trouble getting other
movies made too it was kind of a default
i kind of thought
i'm just gonna maybe this will be the
last movie i ever made i mean no one
wants to give me money to make a movie
i'd made some movies that hadn't done
well
so i was like okay this may be the last
movie you know i just remember
thinking i'm pouring everything into
this one movie i think it's a good way
to work
i kind of have used time as a
structuring device
maybe kind of in place of
um traditional plot you know like that's
kind of
phony to me to a large degree a lot of
that's you know
kind of created whereas time is
something we can all relate to
it's kind of the way we process the
world the way we think
what how we go through life and so much
of
what i'm trying to do is kind of capture
how it feels
you know so i was really trying to not
tell a story about childhood so much as
what it feels like to grow up and in
this case
what it feels like to be a parent too to
try to figure that out
so it's just kind of more the feel so
time for me works
in that you know cinema has this very
special relation with time
that i think is very fertile for um you
know new forms and things
if you really think about it you know
like we've all been at funerals and
really sad times where
people find humor he tells funny stories
about people
humor can be very healing you know in
the bad times
so it's important it's how we kind of
persevere and find some kind of
commonality
a little levity isn't bad i never
trusted
art that's too serious you know if it's
serious subject
treated too serious by the people around
it i just don't believe that because i
think oh the worse things are
the more people are trying to counter
that with humor and
something else another thing as a parent
my daughter was exactly the age of those
kids i think
had i not had a daughter that age i i
would not have been good for that movie
and something in jack's character i
found very personal to me
kind of the the slacker who society's
looking down their nose that is not
productive
person but in fact he does have
something to offer society
you